abel boidé président de la plate forme
de réflexion forces républicaines
abel bouillie merci d'être avec nous en
direct me viens d'écouter à ça à traoré
sort de la victime porte parole du
collectif de soutien il ya bien le dire
pardon enquête dans cette affaire que
des investigations pourquoi cette
affaire reflète un petit peu l'ensemble
de dysfonctionnements de l'appareil
judiciaire
on peut parler des nombreux points
d'interrogations qu'il ya autour
à noter que au départ parmi les
policiers
j'en avais qui avait reconnu hamad
traoré avait supporté le poids des trois
policiers
ensuite ça a été changé lorsque les
pompiers sont arrivés
quelle avait été la première déclaration
technique adama traoré n'était pas en
position latérale de sécurité qu'il
était sur le ventre avec les menottes
mains dans le dos ça a été changé aussi
on ne sait pas pourquoi sans compter que
l'on est dans une affaire qui dure quand
même depuis quatre ans aujourd'hui nous
sommes à une période anniversaire par
rapport à sept matchs il est important
vraiment de comprendre aussi la
souffrance de cette famille parce qu'il
ya eu tout un jeu aussi de communication
de certains de vos confrères qui sont
allés pour discréditer la frappe de
traoré à le chercher
le casier judiciaire adama traoré de ses
frères ou autre alors qu'en réalité
c'était le sujet
la famille de monde juste la vérité par
rapport à une interpellation qui a
semble-t-il dégénéré et qui a causé la
mort et adama traoré et tout ce que
cette famille de monde pouvoir avoir
enfin la liberté de rentrer dans un
deuil mérité et ça soulève beaucoup de
questions cette communication malsaine
duquel mieux est-ce que s'il s'était
appelé jean marc dupont et qu'il aurait
été médecin prédit belle pour autres est
ce qu'on aurait cherché à discréditer la
famille dans ce sens donc l'important
c'est de ne pas chercher à l'utiliser la
forme pourrait toucher le fond vous avez
une famille qui est dans son droit de
rechercher la vérité par rapport à ce
qu'il s'est passé alors dernier fait en
date j'ai envie de vous dire c'est des
zus qui demandent une nouvelle expertise
médicale mais c'est toi si en belgique
pourquoi la belgique vu les différents
épisodes d' expertise qui a eu lieu en
france ne soit qu on est à 4 expertise
sap ou 5 avec à chaque fois des contrats
dits des contradictions
lorsque
demandée par la justice française il ya
une version lorsque s'est demandée par
la famille à une autre version donc dead
qui lie à une volonté de faire cette
nouvelle expertise en terrain neutre
avec des personnes qui ne seraient
sûrement pas influencé par le cours de
la valeur
on attendait donc beaucoup aidé à des
conclusions de ces nouvelles
investigations qui devraient avoir lieu
au mois de janvier je crois nous en
attendons beaucoup parce que de toute
façon nous avons affaire à l'exposition
flagrante du dysfonctionnement de
l'appareil judiciaire ça fait quatre ans
que la palud à ton de pouvoir se reposer
se relever de ce drame que des bombes
dont elle a été frappée
effectivement et puis même par rapport à
tous les jeunes à toutes les personnes
qui soutiennent la cause basse et c'est
devenu quelque part un exemple iconique
pour beaucoup mais il est important de
rappeler que ce n'est pas un combat
contre la police parce là aussi on a
essayé d'utiliser peut-être chapelle
conclusion de communication pour
discréditer
c'est une recherche de vérité par
rapport à quelques éléments au sein de
la police qui ont pu déraper qui ont pu
comme mondiale et ont pu utiliser un
modus operandi qui a amené la mort tama
traoré donc ce n'est pas une vendetta
contre la police police dont nous avons
tous besoin pour veiller à notre
sécurité et je pense à ça traoré a pu le
dire mais il est important pour cette
famille de pouvoir aller au bout de la
chose et je pense que tous tous les
téléspectateurs et les téléspectatrices
que nous sommes nous n'avons pas eu tous
assez de recul nous avons eu nous avons
tous été entraînés par le déferlement
médiatique alors que à la base on a une
famille qui recherche la vérité on a une
famille qui souffre on a une famille qui
pleure le soir on a vu qu'il n'arrive
pas à se relever qui ont plus a été
saluée sur la place publique de la
manière la plus odieuse qui soir et on a
une famille française c'est important de
le rappeler parce ce cas à rêver aussi
beaucoup de crispation et beaucoup de
fractures qu'il y a un sens de la
société j'ai pu voir beaucoup de
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
même par rapport aux différents
rassemblements de jeunes à pied des
français qui pouvaient dire à l'autre
français rentrez chez vous alors que ces
jeunes sont français on a pu dire aussi
que ce soit 10 ans étaient à bout
instrumentalisés par des prêts de gauche
mais je ne pense pas que ces jeunes sont
là pour faire la campagne de jean luc
mélenchon en vue d'une éventuelle
candidature à la présidentielle de 2000
ce sont des personnes qui sont à la
recherche d'une justice sociale qui sont
à la recherche d'une reconnaissance et
qui ont besoin de pouvoir s'identifier à
une représentation iconique pour pouvoir
aussi redonner un sens à leur quotidien
monsieur voyez on a vu que cette marche
aujourd'hui est organisée par le
collectif en soutien adama traoré mais
aussi par un mouvement écologiste
pourquoi cette convergence entre les
deux alors moi je ne veux pas je veux
laisser le bénéfice du doute la seule
mouvement écologiste et je ne peux pas
tomber dans l'accusation facile qui
serait celle de la tentative de
récupération politique
je construis le comité à damas ont rompu
au jeu de la communication ça fait
quatre ans maintenant qu'ils sont qui
sont exposées de façon inégale par nos
membres nous avons tous très bien que ce
suspect ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis avec george clooney qui a une
résonance ici même si le cas français
est le cas américain ne sont pas
identiques mais il y à ce point commun
de la violence policière il à ce point
commun comme je disais tout à l'heure
d'un modus operandi qui peut vraiment
laissé sujet à beaucoup d'interrogations
alors vous avez effectivement c'est
écolo qui sont là moi je se croire
qu'ils sont là pour une recherche de
vérité qui sont là pour apporter un
soutien aux nets et non pas pour une
tentative de récupération politique
n'est pas ton s'ils s'inscrivent bon ça
je pense que se livreraient à un refus
catégorique de la part du comité à damas
alors tout à l'heure monsieur veuillez
vous parliez beaucoup de
dysfonctionnements de l'appareil
judiciaire en france
qu'est ce qui s'est vraiment passé dans
la sphère traoré depuis quatre ans
pourquoi vous dites ya eu un
dysfonctionnement de l'appareil
judiciaire
déjà le fait que ça dure quatre ans il
ya beaucoup trop et même le nouveau
ministre de la justice monsieur eric
dupond moretti a pu le dire je peux le
dire sur vos plaques et là quelques
semaines lors du rassemblement au de
clichy c'est que au début on a quand
même eu en occurrence de la république
et de lui mentir devant les caméras en
affirmant que adama traoré avait dix
foyers infectieux dans le corps
puis après on entendu parler des
britanno sitôt sans compter les
différentes expertises les allers
retours de dossiers d'un bureau à
l'autre que c'est vraiment très
compliqué et vous avez une famille qui
est assise entre deux chaises et qui ne
peut pas aller de l'avant
bien que le fait que ça dure déjà quatre
ans c'est l'incarnation d'un problème
suspect nietzsche au niveau de
l'appareil judiciaire
monsieur ben oui merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous je rappelle que vous
êtes président de la plate forme de
réflexion citoyenne forces républicaines
merci